have you seen what keith reboy is doing
as his new startup
no so you know who he is yeah
so he's the guy who uh uh he was like
ex-paypal then he was the ceo of square
he's
kind of a known investor founder's fund
then he started he's a known
like people think he's a total
on twitter super hilarious to follow
because he's a just absolute jerk to
people
um you know his like number one tweet is
just like wrong
the period and he won't tell you why he
won't argue back he just calls you an
idiot and then if you like try to argue
he's like
this is why i'm i was more successful at
the age of 27 than you are at 40.
and he just like rips people like that
and like who does that that's
nobody does that so i think that's just
like really crazy and entertaining to me
um but anyways he's doing so he did open
door
and what opendoor is is now is like a
publicly listed company because they did
us back
and opendoes a multi-billion dollar
company and basically it was like
selling your house is a time-consuming
and stressful process what if like the
day you want to sell
you could just sell your house right
away give you a price you say yes or no
and that's what opendoor did so they
basically would just buy your house
and then they had a lot of data to know
how much to buy your house for
and then they were the brokers they
could keep the broker fee for themselves
buying and selling and then they would
sell it within like 90 days hopefully
and they do this in a whole bunch of
markets like arizona and stuff like that
and so they've done very well you know
kind of like on paper and like zillow
now
like does the same thing to try to
compete with them they kind of changed
the way that the the business model of
these big
real estate companies worked where now
like the money to be made is in
basically like auto buying your bit auto
buying your house
and then reselling it for you and using
a bunch of technology to do that
anyways his new company he's starting uh
with with jake
jack abraham is uh called open store and
so
we have open door and now you have open
store i no they haven't released a bunch
of details but i think i know what it is
which is
it is open door for buying businesses so
it's the same idea for buying i think
it's going to be
specialized in online businesses but
maybe not um
where basically you just say here's my
business and then they say here's your
offer
we'll buy it off you and um and so i
don't know if this is gonna be
specialized like e-commerce roll-ups
like a thrasio
um i don't know if it's gonna be online
and offline like
um where did you learn about this and
what what can i go
is there a website yet uh they announced
it so i heard about it a few
weeks ago like six weeks ago maybe and i
was like oh that's super interesting
how did you hear about this so somebody
told me about it because
their friend interviewed at the company
and so that's like the only way you
could know about it because like when
you're interviewed they like kind of
tell you the premise of the company
and that guy was like oh dude you know
keith was doing a new thing it's
basically open door for bit buying
businesses
and i was like oh that's sick that's a
great idea because buying
but selling your business is also just
like
is even more than buying a home in terms
of time consuming stressful
uncertain on what price you're going to
get uncertain what price it even should
be
and um and the marketplace is to do that
online like buy biz
buy biz sell or whatever that website is
like.com
they're so like old school you know like
on how they do that and so
um so i think there's like room for
improvement there so i found that to be
really interesting
let me bring this up real quick which is
it's so crazy
how often internet marketers who often
are
accused of being sleazy and many of them
are i mean
they're accused of being that because
they are but they're often ahead of the
game
so for example email marketing email
newsletters are all the rage right now
uh scammy guys like i don't think this
guy's actually scamming me but david
d'angelo he used to sell dating books in
the 1990s
by having these long emails i just stole
and copied from him
um the other thing is paid memberships
paid memberships have been a thing for
decades
now guys like greg your friend our
friend greg is doing
a paid community thing and greg's like a
cool guy um and so it's like
it's like cool to do it um and there's
so many more
and this is another one buying and
selling businesses online
has been a thing that internet marketers
so for example flippa where you could
buy affiliate websites
that's been a thing for years empire
flippers is another one
empire builders and if you go as empire
flippers or empire builders i think
those are actually two things
but they but if you go to those websites
you're gonna
a lot of people are gonna be immediately
turned off you're gonna think what the
is this
and startup guys like us we just
come in i guess that's what we are
we just come in and we take this stuff
that these guys have been doing for
years and we just say
put some lipstick on it yeah one 2.0
make it a flat beautiful color
uh it's so funny because like cool this
sounds
neat but this isn't unique right uh yeah
i think
you know there's no unique ideas really
there's you know remixes of ideas
there's old ideas that you make new
there's new platforms but but i think
it's cool
and i think it could be big uh it's one
i'm going to keep my eye on
then i saw another business like this so
i started to put together a little bit
of a pattern here and i said oh
what is open door for x so what other
parts of life and uh in the world
could use instant liquidity because
that's what this is it's basically
taking something that was kind of
illiquid like your house and
it takes a lot of time to get liquid
where you actually sell the thing
and takes a lot of you know you got to
like you got to move out you got to
stage it you got to repaint it you got
to get a broker you got to list it you
got to do
tours no instant liquidity we buy your
house today
don't do any of that um same thing
with your buying your business
what else needs that and then i saw
another one and this business is called
um i grabbed the name but it's basically
doing this for used electronics it's
called backflip
just got funded and backflip is
basically saying we'll
instantly buy any of your used
electronics and uh because
that's not a new thing either and and i
think it's awesome
and so it's not that it's new it's
basically that there is a
big swing being taken by people who are
going to try to do this
at scale using like the modern kind of
internet marketing
and models to do it and so like you know
like
we buy gold or whatever what else does
billboards cards
you know like gift cards yeah exactly
like um and there's like a gift card
there's actually a gift card startup
that's crushes uh that that basically
took the old bottle and just doesn't
know
what's it called raise i think raised
yeah i'm i'm on their website right now
i'm looking at raise.com
holy i can look at the traffic and
just tell you these guys are printing
money
yeah raise is gonna be like a billion
dollar plus win
uh and nobody even like hears about this
company nobody talks about this company
but
you know super simple business of like
you know gift cards the gift card
business
resale of gift cards essentially and so
uh so anyways i'm interested in this
open door for x which is basically
instant liquidity for things that were
pretty much interesting
all right let's play off that so houses
okay there's equity zen
which i think is badass uh so equities
then
equity's in kind of looks more like
flippa than it does like open door
meaning like it's kind of hard to get in
it's kind of obtuse you got to like sign
up to see
not everything is there it's like a
10-step process to do an investment it's
like
equity zen is not like it's not robin
hood on my phone where i can just like
do my thing and so like secondary shares
yeah it's like a shitty name like i
don't know like it's just bad all around
and forge global
was the other one it's like also bad i
don't know i feel like somebody should
do this better carter is trying to
carter x is trying to do this better
um right now which is like secondary
shares of private companies
yeah i'm not a fan of carta but um i
could see them doing
well but i'm not i'm not a fan of carter
so i don't know if i want them to be the
best at this
um angelus is also trying to do it
there's a bunch of people trying to do
this second
trying to do open door trying to do what
they're trying to do is a little bit
different they're just still trying to
do the marketplace
what opendoor did was different it
wasn't like open door wasn't just
another housing marketplace it was
i will buy the thing off you right now
because i know what i can sell it for
um and i'll i'll i'm comfortable with
this five percent spread that i will
i will keep so you give up five percent
of your upside but you get the certainty
of it being done
now and um and i'm comfortable in that
five percent spread so somebody would
need to do this for secondary shares
would they just go
you want to sell your your company stock
done
and then i will figure out how to
re-flip this thing on the other side
with my own spread
so there's a few people that have done
this with furniture and furniture's
really hard because furniture doesn't
ship well
yeah um but there is if you i don't know
if you know i mean i buy i like buying
used furniture because you can get like
10 dollar couches for like three grand
um and what's oftentimes they're really
nice
used furniture is not really a thing on
the internet uh or at least it's not
hugely popular but
you could i think there is still an
interesting way you can do this with
used furniture
right um so i think training cards is
one so i know a lot of people that have
sports cards they collect it as a kid
it's in their attic somewhere it's in a
box
they kind of heard of cards are worth
something but they don't like they don't
know what they have they don't know what
it's worth
they don't have them graded they didn't
send them into psa and pay the money to
get them graded
so i think if somebody basically did the
shoebox model where you basically say
put it all in a shoebox and mail it to
us and we will pay you for it
uh we'll do all the work of figuring out
what it's worth and then we'll pay you
you know 70 cents on the dollar for for
what it's worth and like today you're
getting nothing for it and like
that that's the and if if you don't like
our offer we'll send it back
and i think that somebody did that they
could just hoover up all the long tail
of like trading cards that are out there
um that people are not doing anything
with that they want to monetize
that's interesting okay so uh we've
we've
furniture is not that good trading cards
are pretty interesting because it's a
lot easier
cars everyone a lot of people do cars
carvana does cars and i think that that
is so sick they're a multi-billion
dollar
is that the same model they use where
they'll just instantly buy your car off
you
yeah like they'll buy it in a matter of
minutes which if you told me this like
years ago i'd be like no way that
can't be done but they made uh 5.6
billion dollars last year in sales so it
worked okay so it's working open door
for cars
working yeah yeah it totally works um
what else is interesting what's a huge
thing like what's what are some of the
bigger assets that you possibly have in
your life that you want to
wow carvana's market cap is 45 billion
dollars
holy yeah it's working um
what else is there i don't know there's
gonna be some obscure like oh like
life insurance policy
payouts or something or like you know
like something like that that i'm like i
don't even know that space
but that makes sense it takes you know
it's something that you get or like
social security like
i know like my parents are getting to
the age where they can collect social
security
like would they take a lump sum of all
their social security now
and you know at 70 cents or 72 cents on
the dollar
and then you know this company just
collects the payments over time like
probably i don't know like there's a lot
of people who would make that trade dude
did you know this so there's this uh a
company i have to go and look at what it
is but you guys could probably google it
actually but i think some banks do it
like goldman will do it
but if you have a winning lottery ticket
they'll buy it off you right and they'll
give you the money up front
and it's structured in such a way where
they're they're still able to make their
profit
but they'll buy lottery tickets from you
like we're talking like 10 million
lottery tickets or seven figures uh i uh
it's kind of interesting people buy
winning lottery tickets off of people
that's actually kind of an interesting
one i would actually need to do some
research how many people do
how much money do you think is one in
the lottery per year
oh dude i have no idea i mean i feel
like the weekly lottery the powerball
every week is like you know between 50
and like 200 million dollars it's like
it's like
that's that's like on a weekly basis
that it now it doesn't get one every
week that's how it accrues and that's
how it gets bigger but like
you know i don't know you have the
number in front of you i feel like it's
i don't know no i uh no i
i can't find it there there's 1600
lotteries created each year
so there's at least 1600 unique winners
um
no i don't i don't have the numbers but
lottery tickets might actually be kind
of interesting because you
said the life insurance i'm like what do
you wait to get paid for that you would
take a discounted upfront payment
lotteries is kind of is actually kind of
interesting um and i do know that some
banks actually do that
right you know who else does that is
whitey bulger you remember whitey bulger
i've never even heard that those words
in my life do you do
you know the movie the departed yes you
know jack nicholas's character
okay yes it's modeled after whitey
bulger he was a gangster
in uh boston he was an italian or an
irish mafia guy
he uh or a mobster guy he ended up going
to jail recently they found him
and they um um he got beat to death in
jail so it was like a
crazy ending to the story of him he was
america's most wanted man for like
20 years and um anyway he
as part of his story he won the lottery
three times and the way that he did it
is people who had won the lottery that
in the neighborhood
they would have to go to him and he
would buy it from you and he would go
and cash the ticket
and uh so this is like a fame like the
numbers game they call it that's like a
famous mafia thing
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back